[Musique]
à l'occasion de la Journée de la Femme
la mafar EPE a organisé des animations
et des débats à l'espace redley à
Saint-Denis on voulait déjà d'abord
mettre notre association en avant les
les membres de nos adhérents en fait
donc on a choisi de faire cette journée
ici et leur faire profiter d'activités
qui sont pas forcément accessibles en
général ne serait-ce que peut-être par
moyen ou par accessibilité moyen de
transport donc on a décidé de tout
centraliser ici et de l'ouvrir aussi aux
personnes extérieures qui sont pas
forcément de notre de notre association
c'est aussi l'occasion d'avoir un
rassemblement où les femmes venant
d'horizons différents peuvent échanger
de façon très très libre très
convivial c'est ce qu'on voulait on
puisse faire émerger des rapports qui
peuvent se nouer qui par la suite
peuvent perdurer et et donner des
résultats la mafar EPE est affilié à une
fédération nationale des écoles des
parents et des éducateurs qui rassembl
une quarantaine d'associations dont la
vocation est de travailler en matière de
parentalité et de conjugalité on
développe un certain nombre d'actions
périphériques par exemple la lutte
contre
[Applaudissements]
l'ilérisme d'autres actions en matière
de de lutte contre les stéréotypes
sexiste
en matière d'éducation affective et
sexuelle auprès des jeunes au niveau des
collèges par
exemple plusieurs association et
institutions partenaires de l'opération
étai présents tels que la mission locale
la CGSS ou encore le Pôle Emploi les
participants ont également pu profiter
d'ateliers de manucure de coiffure de
massage afin qu'ell soit choyée pour
cette journée en leur honneur à la
demande de l'association de la mafar
donc en cette Journée internationale des
droits de de la femme donc nous sommes
venus à la rencontre de de ces femmes
pour leur offrir des soins de détente de
bien-être par le BIA des de modelage les
soins de maquillage les soins de coiure
pour redonner un petit peu l'estime de
soi et retrouver surtout la sensation du
bien-être par le toucher avec nos
professionnels ici bénéolle aujourd'hui
en l'honneur de la journée
internationale au droit de la femme
euh je suis venue présenter mes
prestations de tatouage temporaire au aé
je voulais faire découvrir un petit peu
ce côté oriental indien à la population
réunionnaise et je voulais permettre de
se faire belle également parce que c'est
quand même leur fête c'est en leur
honneur donc nous avons tous le droit de
prendre du temps pour soi et de se faire
belle la journée s'est terminée par le
vernissage de l'exposition photo de Joë
Pellerin en collaboration avec son époux
20 tableaux photographiques accompagnés
d'autant de
poèmes je travaille beaucoup sur la
femme je pense que la femme c'est
vraiment l'avenir de l'humanité que la
première fois que tout être humain
connaît l'amour c'est avec sa mère donc
c'est particulièrement dans cette
exposition la femme son univers avec ses
différents états célibatair marié
enceintes et avec ses enfants et l'homme
n'est pas oublié plus bien sûr mes
poèmes véhiculent des messages des
messages que je vois au cours de mes
consultations les problématiques de vie
et j'essaie de les traduire en poème
pour que ce soit plus facile à passer
comme
message une journée d'échange et de
partage où les femmes ont pu se
rencontrer dans un environnement de
bien-être et de
convivialité
[Musique]